some who witnessed the attacks that are
simply visiting Las Vegas shared how
scary it was as police continue to
investigate tonight Sasha loft is
joining us live now from UMC Sasha has
more Denise and Brian some of those
victims still recovering here at UMC
tonight and as you mentioned one of them
is still critical now at the same time
Witnesses tourists and even police say
this tragic random event is hard to
comprehend
I've seen a crime scene I've seen the
police I've seen the Yellow Tape shock
and fear still felt hours after violence
erupted on the Las Vegas Strip this guy
came ran up and started stabbing this
lady in front of me
walked outside we saw you know we
started hurting what was happening and
more and more eight people were stabbed
in front of the win on Thursday two of
them Las Vegas locals 47 year old Brent
Hallett and 30 year old Maris digiovanni
are now dead with another also in
critical condition we want to extend our
heartfelt condolences to the families of
the victims and to the victims
themselves Metro Police say a Hispanic
man in his 30s carried out the attack
randomly with a large kitchen knife then
as you can see in this video officers
released he ran from the scene and was
later arrested I'm very proud of lvnpd
and our ability to be eyes on and
physically on to take this suspect into
custody in a matter of minutes
authorities are now assuring the
community there's no larger threat it's
crazy to happen on the ship where it's
like a lot of tourists and stuff but
still many say this will make them more
aware of the dangers anyone can face
that would be so violent and have
something to hate in them police say
they do not believe the suspect here was
from Las Vegas they were also able to
retrieve the weapon described as a large
kitchen knife in this attack now of
course stay with 8 news now as this
story continues to develop both on air
and online reporting live tonight soccer
Loftus 8 News Now